hey guys so about two years ago i
uploaded a video which asked a very
simple question to you the audience
which was how was your day and honestly
it was one of the most interesting
experiences of my entire youtube career
just reading what my audience was up to
on that given day
and somebody suggested actually in the
comments recently i revisited it um that
i should do it again and so i thought
i've had a pretty momentous day i'm
actually moving house at the moment
which is why i have all of my detritus
here and i'm actually uh it's been a
very interesting day which is why i'm
not in my new house just yet i've had a
few issues but i thought that this is um
you know as soon as i've had an
interesting day i want to learn about
your day so today is july the 4th i mean
i suppose
whenever you watch this really just
reply with what your day has been like
that could be as soon as i upload it or
it could be tomorrow or a week or
whatever but
just leave in the comments what you've
been up to and
i think you know what you think it might
be banal and maybe it's just been a bit
boring
the little details about what you've
been up to and how that differs across
all the people that watch my videos i
find really really interesting and maybe
you'll be able to make some friends in
the comments of people who have had
similar days or might be into similar
things
so simple question
how was your day
put it down there